we operate with some stock images of the
addict a person with a heroin needle in
a park or who nurses a bottle of gin in
a paper bag at 9:00 in the morning or
who sneaks off at every opportunity to
light up another cylinder of marijuana
however dramatic and tragic such cases
of addiction might be they are
simultaneously hugely reassuring to most
of us because they locate the addict far
from ordinary experience somewhere
offstage in the land of semi criminality
and outbreak there are such examples are
dangerously flattering categorizing
addiction in a sentimental way that lets
most of us off the hook and at the same
time cuts us off from identification
with and therefore sympathy for the most
wretched victims of addiction there are
in truth far more addicts than we think
indeed if we look at the matter squarely
we are pretty large full addicts the
official statistics on the consumption
of hard drugs and alcohol don't begin to
give a fair representation of the issue
we need to define addiction in a new way
addiction is the manic reliance on
something anything in order to keep our
dark or unsettling thoughts at bay
what properly indicates addiction is not
what someone is addicted to for we can
get addicted to
pretty much anything it is the motives
behind their reliance on it and in
particular their desire to avoid
encountering the contents of their own
mind being inside our minds is for most
of us and very understandably a deeply
anxiety inducing prospect
we're filled with thoughts we don't want
properly to entertain and feelings we're
desperate not to feel there is an
infinite amount of with angry and sad
about that it would take an uncommon
degree of courage to face up to we
experienced a host of fantasies and
desires that we have a huge incentive to
disavow because of the extent to which
they violate our self-image and our more
normative commitments we shouldn't pride
ourselves because we aren't injecting
something into our veins
almost certainly we are doing something
people can affect we're checking the
news at four minute intervals to keep
the news from ourselves at bay we're
doing sport exhausting our bodies in the
hope of not having to hear from our
minds we're using work to get away from
the true internal work with shirking the
most compelling addictions can sound
very righteous to the world to get a
measure of our levels of addiction we
need only consider when the last time
might have been that we were able to sit
alone in a room with our own thoughts
without distraction free associating
therein to wander into the past and
future allowing ourselves to feel pain
desire regret and excitement we may
start to see how much we have in common
with a traditional addict when we come
face-to-face with them we're not meeting
anything especially foreign just a part
of ourselves in a less respectable form
opening up new opportunities for
kindness towards them and us we could
start a think to at how we might wean
ourselves off our shows an addictive of
a suit
we need to lose our fear of our minds we
need a collective sense of safety around
confronting loss humiliation sexual
desire and sadness knowing that we will
have to keep running away so long as we
do not rehabilitate our feelings on the
other side of addiction is in a sense
philosophy philosophy understood as the
patient unfrequent compassionate
examination of the contents of our own
minds
thank you for watching liking and
subscribing if you want more why not
visit us in person and attend a class or
take a look at our shop at the link on
your screen now